[Musik]
geehrt biggs ist das mantra von
amazon.com und seinem stürmischen
gründer
von dem moment an als ich dort anfing
haben wir das gaspedal immer stärker
durch getreten der kühne unternehmer hat
die regeln des handels neu geschrieben
alle hatten es eilig bei der open des
internets der stadt vergessen sie
etablieren
seine strategie zahlte sich nicht aus
auch nach dem börsengang haben sich die
leute die finanzdaten angeguckt und
gesagt die werden das nicht schaffen
amazon.com war im dezember 95
tatsächlich
ungefähr für eine stunde wurde klar
schachzügen baute jeff bezos amazon.com
auf und oma sahen dort k wenn du eine
frage stellst auf die jf nicht wirklich
eingehen will dann ist die antwort die
du kriegst einen lachen
und land hat er jede menge geld gemacht
auf amazon kannst du alles kaufen vom
books bücher musik schuhe bis hin zu
kampfpanzern oder ticket
amazon ist der erfolgreichste online
händler der welt
und wird immer noch von dem mann geführt
der ihn gegründet hat
der einzige ort zu sein an dem man
praktisch alles kaufen kann gesagt im
einzelhandelsmarkt erhältlich ist es war
ein entscheidender teil der
wachstumsstrategie des unternehmens
das öffentliche bild von jeff bezos ist
das eine super helden und das ist er ist
risiken eingegangen er hat probleme
gelöst und er hat milliarden von dollar
an vermögen angehäuft als privatperson
ist base zurückhaben salz und der
öffentlichkeit und er lehnte es ab an
unserem programm teilzunehmen
wurde am 12 januar 1964 in albuquerque
new mexico geboren als sohn von jackie
einer 17 jährigen gymnasiasten
kreis ließ sich von seinem leiblichen
vater scheiden und heiratete einen
kubanischen einwanderer und exxon erdöl
ingenieur
miguel adoptierte das vierjährige kind
beschrieb seine frühen computer
erfahrungen 2001 in einem interview mit
der academy of the shipment
eine firma news nach dieser kleinen
grundschule groß öffnen
keiner der lehrer wusste computer
bedient niemand wusste aber
es gab einen stapel bücher
kann ich schon ein paar andere kinder
blieben nach dem unterricht und werden
und das ding programm
teenager versuchte sich base zum ersten
mal als unternehmer mit einem sommercamp
mit den schwerpunkten wissenschaft und
literatur
fünf studenten meldeten sich an für 150
dollar pro kopf
1986 schloss er sein elektrotechnik und
informatik studium an der princeton
university mit summa cum laude ab
microsd-karten ist redakteur bei
business insider dass und berichtet seit
sechs jahren über amazon
bekam einen job bei einem hedgefonds
namens die show er wollte nicht im
finanzwesen arbeiten sondern als
computer programmierer und die show war
genau das der hedgefond basierte auf
algorithmen und der art von technologie
für die sich besseres interessierte
es war nicht das einzige das ihn
interessiert hat dies auf eine statistik
die ihn überrascht dass das internet pro
jahr um 2.300 aus er war einfach
besessen von dieser zahl des budgets des
namens sah sich die 20 größten
versandhändler und witterte seine chance
im internet
chris anderson damals chefredakteur des
magazins wired
diesen technologischen tsunami kommt der
ganz neue vertriebskanäle schaffen würde
er würde die wirtschaft neu definieren
und die art und weise ändern wie wir
kauften und verkauften und so die frage
war in welchem bereich sollten wir das
anwenden die antwort waren bücher eine
wahre für die es keinen umfassenden
katalogs ist im juli 1994 kündigte er
seinen sicheren job an der wall street
und seinen traum zu verwirklichen
eine der ersten online buchhandlungen
der welt his first investors seine
ersten investoren warum seine eltern mir
geschieht mit die erste frage meines
vaters war was ist das internet nicht
auf die firma oder das konzept gewettet
im sommer 94 machten sich base und seine
frau mackenzie auf dem weg in den staat
washington steckt bewaffnet mit 300.000
dollar von seinen eltern die technologie
experten esther dyson ist vorsitzende
der investorenfirma adventure holding ab
welche logik nun ja es gibt viele leute
die die wallstreet verlassen um eigene
startup zu gründen aber anders werde
viel erfahrung gesammelt und dann hat er
etwas erstaunliches geschaffen
und seine frau ließen sich in bellevue
washington nieder und stellten zwei
programmierer
erzählt dir darüber in einer rede am
lake forest
fand ein haus das als geschäftigen
könnte ist eine garage das passe es gibt
doch all diese geschichten von startup
zu garagen es
war nicht ganz legitim weil es eine
umfunktionierte anbau garage war sie war
nicht isoliert es waren wirklich keine
beeindruckenden büros
die firma
nach dem scheinbar endlosen fluss in
südamerika mit seinen unzähligen
nebenflüssen am 16 juli 95 öffnete
amazon.com seine virtuellen türen
james markus war mitarbeiter nummer 55
er sollte damals buchbesprechungen
schreiben die nichts weiter als eine
liste von titeln ein als ich mir die
website angeguckt habe um zu sehen ob
ich da wirklich arbeiten will stellte
ich fest wie rudimentär sie war es gab
eine titelseite mit einer bunten
mischung von büchern aber das
bemerkenswerteste war es gab einen
riesigen katalog mit mehreren
hunderttausend titeln wurde aber gar
keinen inhalt hatte
amazon.com hatte kein werbe budget die
ersten umsätze wurden ausschließlich
über mundpropaganda erzählt
geschäftsführer
es war wirklich von anfang an ganz
anders
waren nicht in silicon valley sie waren
in seattle und sie haben auch bei diesen
ganzen hype nicht mitgemacht und jeden
tag pressemitteilungen herausgegeben
doch die seite setzte sich durch
innerhalb eines monats hatte amazon
kunden in allen 50 bundesstaaten und 45
weiteren ländern
amazon gut geführt er war organisiert er
war stand den vertrieb distribution
ihren verstand des menschen zum kaufen
zu motivieren hinter tat die dinge mit
brier liebe zum detail
dieses ziel könnte in einer einfachen
zeile zusammengefasst
war ein mantra und auch eine
strategische entscheidung ich alles
musste gedopt sein das ganze wachstum
musste gedopt sein
von 1999 bis 2001 manager für
geschäftsentwicklung bei amazon
alle hatten es eilig das internet zu
erobern ein sieg um das marktanteile zu
kommen
wie können wir die marke amazon
etablieren und das geschäft ausbauen
happy ex kosten der wettbewerber und
innerhalb eines sehr kleinen zeitfenster
die strategie zahlte sich aus wenn die
1996 hat er das unternehmen einen umsatz
von 15 7 millionen dollar die gewinne
wurden dadurch gesteigert dass amazon
den meisten kunden steuerfreies
einkaufen an bord
was uns ausmacht ist die große auswahl
und komfort direkt bis zur haustür und
wir sind der größte discounter der welt
wir bieten über 300.000 titel billiger
die meistverkauften titel das sind
doppelt so viele wie die größte
physische buchhandlung anbieten kann
aber die investoren waren frustriert
werden der umsatz stieg ohne gewinne
amazon gab millionen aus um software zu
entwickeln um das geschäft auszubauen
das unternehmen ging in dieser zeit
viele risiken ein und ich glaube es gab
viele spekulationen darüber dass das
richtige war oder nicht
leicht zurück zu blicken und zu sagen
sie mussten so viel investieren um diese
größe zu erreichen die sie heute haben
aber das war nicht vom ersten tag an
klar
klar war das base nicht auf
hielt das tempo durch den börsengang von
amazon fahren die idee war dass man sich
nicht einen moment auf seinen lorbeeren
ausruht dass man einfach ständig
innovativ sein und sich von der
konkurrenz fernhalten muss und keine
millisekunde lang selbstgefällig ist
am 15 bei 97 wurde die aktie an der
nasdaq börse zu einem preis von 29
dollar 25 pro aktie gehandelt
dollar über dem ausgabepreis
der tag des eigentlichen börsengangs war
eine echt große sache überall in der
firma gab es partys chef rief uns aus
new york an und sagte wir haben heute
geschichte geschrieben
wir haben alle heute geschichte
geschrieben
es war verdammt aufregend aber
trotz des gelungenen börsengangs hat
einen tag analysten immer noch so ihre
zweifel
tim o'reilly ist gründer und ceo von
o'reilly media
damals dachten viele dass amazon
untergehen würde sie nahmen die finanzen
genau unter die lupe und sagten dieses
unternehmen wird nie profitabel sein es
gab viele nein sager
amazon arbeite hart daran die website zu
aktualisieren und funktionen wie one
click shopping einzuführen
97 hat sich der aktienwert fast
verdrängt
sagte damals achte nicht auf den
aktienkurs er war zuversichtlich dass er
auf lange sicht immer weiter steigen
würde aber er hielt es für sehr
gefährlich ihm kurzfristig zu betrachten
amazon setzte seine rasante expansion
fort stellte über 7.000 mitarbeiter ein
und verstärkte seine produktpalette
wir haben über praktisch alles geredet
wir könnten lebensmittel verkaufen
hygiene-artikel handys und handytarife
zeitschriften und auch hardware
gartenschläuche und spielzeug das
größere angebot und der hohe absatz
zahlten sich aus für amazon.com als auch
für base
am 20 dezember 99 wurde er vom daimler
gesehen zur person des jahres
meine mutter hat geweint
das 40 dollar es war die ultimative
bestätigung seines traums die welt mit e
commerce zu erobern wenn sie durch das
magazin blättern sehen sie jeff als
indiana jones der an einer liane
schwingt es machte ihn in gewisser weise
zu einem amerikanischen volkshelden es
ist als hätte porta nyon den flur unter
sein büro
ganz oben ist eine katastrophe die ganze
branche erschüttert
der 90er jahre bei amazon einer internet
dampfwalze
aber im jahr 2000 platzte die blase
die aktienkurse brachen ein und auf
basels war zu drastischen maßnahmen
gezwungen
es gab zwei entlassungswellen und wie so
oft weiß man nicht wer gehen muss mann
kauert in seinem büro und wartet darauf
dass die personalabteilung kommt und mit
dem finger auf jemanden zeigt und es tut
weh kollegen gehen zu sehen
angesichts des rückgangs der wirtschaft
und des verbrauchervertrauens war dass
die einzig vernünftige entscheidung die
wir treffen konnten
im september 2001 erreichte die aktie
des unternehmens ein allzeittief bei
bedarf mit fünf dollar 97
vom aushängeschild zum prügelknaben
es ist nicht die art von aktien die man
besitzt und dann gut schläft man ein
kleiner investor ist
übrigens für alle internet aktien
der vorteil den amazon hatte war sie
hatte sich sozusagen diese kriegskasse
angelegt um sowas finanzieren zu können
jesus hat hoch gewettet aber nicht alle
wetten haben sich ausgezahlt am anfang
hat das unternehmen lange keinen profit
gemacht der grund warum jeff bezos damit
durchkam war dass er immer direkt mit
seinen mitarbeitern und den
anteilseignern war
im januar 2002 begannen sich die wetten
endlich auszuzahlen
der aktienkurs erholte sich und nach
sieben jahren machte base unternehmen
endlich wieder gewinnen ist
das beste was ich über ihn sagen kann
ist seine unerschütterliche zuversicht
wusste dass die skeptiker zu kurzfristig
dachten sie seien nicht das große ganze
und er hielt immer an seine vision fest
als die blase geplatzt war hatten die
investoren keine geduld mehr für
unternehmen die sagten wir investieren
in den aufbau einer dot com seite in
unserem geschäft
das nutzte amazon aus und arbeitete mit
target und toys r us und gelb und
anderen einzelhändlern zusammen
der internethandels riese tat sich mit
mehr als 400 zusammen aber nicht alle
einzelhändler waren und willige partner
ich kenne eine reihe von fällen in denen
er unternehmen erworben hat um
potenzielle zukünftige wettbewerber
auszuschalten doch und nicht weil er
deren geschäft wirklich weiterführen
wollte börsen hausse ticketing wizcom
nachdem sein unternehmen wieder auf kurs
konzentrierte sich bei songs auf eine
ganz andere leidenschaft und passion
am 6 märz 2003 startete er einen
helikopter um sich abgelegene gegenden
in texas anzuschauen
er wollte grundstücke kaufen für ein
technologieunternehmen das er im jahr
2000 gegründet hatte dem senkrechtstart
und senkrecht lande raketen für die
bemannte raumfahrt zu entwickeln
die reise endete fast in einer
katastrophe
kurz nach dem start geriet der
helikopter ins trudeln lebt und landete
in einem flussbett
[Musik]
2003 starb jeff bezos fast bei einem
hubschrauberabsturz
es ist wie ein muster er macht etwas
schlimmes durch wie einen internet crash
und dann philosophiert er darüber und
lachte es einfach weg des bislang
im gegensatz zur space exploration
ventures das von privaten geldgebern wie
elon musk richard branson und john
carmack finanziert wird ist besessen
davon blue origin gering zu halten
es war aus verschiedenen gründen
ziemlich geheimnisvoll und dass sich der
raumfahrtindustrie ist das eigentlich
schade was einen guten markt ausmacht
ist wenn ein haufen konkurrenten offen
miteinander konkurriert und versucht
sich gegeneinander zu positionieren sie
konkurrieren um geld sie konkurrieren um
menschen
nach sechs jahren arbeit hinter
verschlossenen türen hoch die seltsam
aussehende testrakete von blue origin
[Applaus]
und base war dabei einen weiteren
revolutionären versucht zu starten
diesmal weniger weit weg
das war eine gelegenheit die buchbranche
enorm zu erweitern und die definition
dessen was ein buch sein kann aber es
brauchte jemanden mit ausreichend
schlagkraft um diese zusammenführung von
hardware software durchzuführen
nur amazon war in der lage das zu tun am
19 november 2007 namen base an der
church road ein und kündigte ein
bahnbrechendes neues produkt
ich hatte hier in händen wovon wir reden
es heißt tindall sagen sie mir wann sie
zum ersten mal auf die idee kam dass so
etwas möglich sein würde
und zwar klar geworden dass es einige
technologien gab die irgendwie zusammen
und dass wir mit dem richtigen rezept
etwas erschaffen konnten von dem wir
hoffen das ist die welt des
elektronischen lesens verändern würde
dann hat dieses gerät auf den markt
gebracht ebenso viele der ästhetischen
vorteile von echten büchern fehlten du
kannst die seiten nicht mehr riechen
keine eselsohren mehr rein machen aber
all die buchliebhaber die dieses ding
gefürchtet haben lieben es jetzt
der 399 dollar teure reader war nur ein
halb stunden ausverkauft
die genauen verkaufszahlen bleiben
allerdings ein streng gehütetes
geheimnis vom unternehmen heißt es man
wolle sie nicht veröffentlicht
winfried melzer ceo von harper collins
und das mitbegründerin von open road
integrated media
niemand weiß wie viele kinder ist es
wirklich gibt das ist ein ratespiel wir
wissen dass es millionen gibt aber wie
viele millionen aber es ist
offensichtlich die strategie von amazon
sie halten viele informationen unter
verschluss aber
für viele verlage war der kindle ein
branchenkenner
es wird in den nächsten jahren echtes
blut im verlagswesen fließen weil die
verlage nicht früh genug bemerkt haben
dass amazon an konkurrent ist
[Musik]
während der kinder große wellen auf dem
e-book-markt schlug bereitete amazon
seine bisher größte
unternehmensakquisition von
toni schießt
cio.com amerikas führendem online
schuhhändler
als ich 2004 jeff bezos zum ersten mal
traf sagte er sei daran interessiert
servus zu kaufen damals sagten wir
werden kein interesse als absagen wie
seine identität verlieren würde
zögerte an amazon zu verkaufen
sie haben sich wieder bei uns gemeldet
und gesagt dass sie sich auch vorstellen
können dass wir unabhängig bleiben
das könnten wirklich großartige partner
sein
im sommer 2009 kaufte amazon den
angesagten online schuhhändler zappos
investoren erhielten zehn millionen
amazon aktien im wert von rund 12
milliarden
sie bekamen aktien die zu diesem
zeitpunkt besser als bargeld waren und
das zeigt dass jeff bezos jemand ist der
die konkurrenz über rollen kann wenn es
sein muss der aber auch bereit ist zu
verhandeln um zu bekommen was er will
und dabei aber alle reicher zu machen
der schuh fasste aber ein goldesel der
kindle bekam ernsthafte konkurrenz von
einem technologieriesen
und wir nahmen 27 januar 2010 brachte
apple das ipad auf dem markt das auch
als lesegerät passiert war
base reagierte aggressiv senkte die
kosten und fügte seinem e-reader neue
funktionen hinzu eine sache die bessere
als amazon chef schon immer gerne getan
hat ist das spielen mit sehr engen
maschen die preissenkung des kindle
zeigt das besser erkannt hatte wo der
wirklich langfristige gewinn für amazon
liegt
nämlich der anbieter zu sein wo jeder
seine bücher kauft und der kindle ist
das gerät mit dem man sie bekommt
doch was kann man einem wachstum das
e-book mag das ruinierte viele bücher
die amazon kam auf die bühne und wurde
zum konkurrenten der einzelhändler sie
waren jetzt der händler
das unternehmen borders hätte ihr
untergang sein können aber der
buchhändler hat seinem gesamten
digitalen verkauf über amazon
abgewickelt hätte er seine eigene
präsenz aufgebaut wäre die situation
heute
nach angaben der autoren innung kaufte
amazon bücher in großhandel für 12 bis
13 dollar und verkaufte sie als kindle
bücher für neun euro 99 machte also
jedes mal verlust
dieses
wenn ein buch 10 dollar wert ist sei es
ein preis reduziert das hardcover
books für den kindle wenn wir jetzt bei
10 dollar sind dann wird sich die ganze
branche verändern wir werden
buchhandlung verlieren
andere sahen darin eine gelegenheit
sehen sie sich all die autoren haben die
durch den kindle die möglichkeit bekamen
eine direkte kundenbeziehung aufzubauen
ich glaube das macht amazon zum gewinner
des ganzen weil sie eine brücke zwischen
autoren und lesern gebaut haben die es
bisher so nicht gegeben hat
das meldete insolvenz an und auch bahn
sind nobel die größte buchhandelskette
hatte zu kämpfen
2011 stieg amazon.com außerdem in den
video streaming markt ein
team des tv redakteur für das magazin
variety
ich glaube wenn sie netflix sind sehen
sie in amazon einen echten konkurrenten
amazon hat online viel anziehungskraft
sie haben tiefe taschen um genau so
viele titel zu kaufen sie stehen hier
zwar noch ganz am anfang aber mit der
zeit könnte amazon genau so groß werden
wie netflix
doch der internet riese ist mit
wachsendem widerstand gegen seine
unversteuerten online-umsatz
konfrontiert
mehrere staaten verlangen lokale
umsatzsteuer
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt und macht
hat seine finger in jedermanns prüfen er
hat videostreaming das mit netflix
konkurriert er macht musik die mit apple
und itunes konkurriert gerückt sogar mit
einem eigenen app store google auf die
pelle
etwas sieht mit dem amazon ein bisschen
geld verdienen und seinen dünnen margen
helfen kann dann wird er es tun
hat es weit gebracht und sein weltraum
projekt sogar noch weiter
im april 2011 bekam blue origin 22
millionen dollar von der nasa stücken
für die entwicklung seines raumfahrzeug
bloomberg setzte base auf platz 20 der
reichsten menschen der welt mit einem
geschätzten nettovermögen von 25
milliarden dollar
amazon.com bleibt der weltweit größte
online händlern er ist nicht nur ein
visionär er ist ein architekt mit
verliehen und einer vorstellung davon
wie man dinge zum laufen bringt er denkt
sehr sorgfältig über design struktur und
betrieb nach und das macht aus einem
besen jahr jemand der tatsächlich etwas
hätte amazon ambanis and noble oder an
andere buchhändler verkaufen und viele
millionen dollar machen können sowie mit
anfang 30 seitdem
kommt er immer wieder mit richtig guten
mädels
diese nahe beijing
er ist nicht der harte typ der über
leichen geht er ist jemand der seine
vision hat wie er dieses unternehmen
aufbauen möchte und er ist in der lage
sich mit leuten zu umgeben die sich
darauf einlassen
ich denke dass es letztendlich einer der
gründe warum er so erfolgreich ist
[Musik]
reed hastings scheint so zu sein wie
seine dvds praktisch unverwüstlich er
hat die welt des films und des
fernsehens verändern
zweimal wir vermieten dvds zum
pauschalpreis ganz einfach er ist einer
der leute die die videotheken getötet
haben werden nichts lieber getan als
netflix abzuwehren er trotzdem seinen
kritikern und setzte auf filme per post
als dvd s noch die meisten investoren
dachten dass netflix nur ein weiteres
dot com ist eine kleine nischen idee
dass die leute kein abo wollen und es
sich nie durchsetzen wird
setzte sich durch sein wert stieg
innerhalb von zwölf jahren auf zwölf
milliarden dollar bis ein fataler fehler
das wachstum stoppte netflix abonnenten
flüchten massenhaft mehr als 800.000
kunden haben im letzten quartal
gekündigt einige leute sagten es wäre
als hätten aliens die macht über seinen
körper übernommen hastings ist
entschlossen den ruf seines unternehmens
wiederherzustellen
kommt wie ein typischer silicon valley
manager sehr zurückhaltend aber er ist
einer von denen die gewinnen müssen
zehn zwölf jahren als wir mit netflix
angefangen haben nicht das internet noch
über aol ein wahlwerber
wurde klar hey die netzwerke werden
wachsen und alle videos werden klicken
watch videos im internet alle
reed hastings machte karriere indem er
die zukunft vorhersagt zuerst mit einem
software-tool dann mit einer einfachen
dvd und einer 32 cent briefmarke
sie werden niemanden finden der mehr
antrieb hat als reed hastings denke er
denkt ständig über die nötigen
strategischen veränderungen
er ist ein unglaublich zielstrebiger
innovativer mensch der so klug ist wie
unfassbar klug einfach
ist einer dieser typen die nicht gerne
viel über sich selbst
wer glaubt dass seine taten zeigen wie
gut er ein unternehmen führen kann
getreu diesem motto wollte er auch mit
uns nicht über sich selbst reden
hastings wurde 1960 in boston
massachusetts geboren und wuchs im
vorort balmont auch der ehemalige
gouverneur gray davis ist ein freund von
ihr stammt aus der mittelschicht sein
vater war anwalt die familie war nicht
sehr wohlhabend bildung war der grund
für seinen erfolg
dazu gehörte ein bachelor abschluss am
boden
er verbrachte einen sommer in einem
ausbildungsprogramm der us-marine
erkannte aber dass das militär nichts
für ihn war
er trat dem frieden scorpio
unterrichtete zwei jahre lang und
trampte dann mit zehn dollar in der
tasche durch afrika zu
unterrichten inspirierte ihn der charlie
rose 2005 erzählt
also ich war high school mathelehrer im
schreiben
ich liebe das unterrichten ich habe
highschool mathe unterrichtet und das
war einfach eine fantastische erfahrung
als er in die usa zurückkehrte machte er
in stanford seinen master in informatik
und bekam eine stelle bei dem
technologieunternehmen enwave
corporation mark buchs ist ein start up
investor der hastings zu beginn einer
neuen ära der computer programmierung
kennenlernte
sagte wissen sie bis jetzt entstand
jedes programm das erstellt wurde im
wesentlichen im kopf einer person
aber jetzt kommen wir an den punkt an in
23 15 leute ein programm schreiben
müssen und wenn das passiert gibt es
probleme bei der koordination zwischen
den leuten und das führt zu vielen
fehlern
fehler von denen hastings glaubte sie
beheben zu können er schrieb ein
programm und gründete mit marc box die
firma pure software die alle
perfektionisten wollte hastings die
besten einstellen und tat alles um sie
zu bekommen
damals software manager bei cadence
design systems
ich wollte die firma bei der ich war
nicht verlassen aber dann kam man mit
einem sixpack bier in meine wohnung und
wir fingen an zu reden das ist seine
typische art
lotterie mclane war eine von hastings
ersten investoren und ein
vorstandsmitglied
sobald wir loslegten gab es kein halten
mehr das geschäft verdoppelte sich jedes
jahr vier jahre in folge eine richtige
rakete
1995 hatte peer software den heiligen
gral der startups erreicht dem
börsengang am eröffnungstag schossen die
aktien um 75 prozent in die höhe
ex es war sehr aufregend
1995 waren wir für eine woche der
erfolgreichste börsengang des jahres in
der woche danach ging netscape an die
börse und stellte alles in den schatten
der erfolg brachte hastings auf die
titelseite von usa today vor seinem
auffälligen neuen porsche carrera ein
foto das er später bereuen sollte cliff
adwords technologie reporter bei
bloomberg businessweek
er hatte das gefühl dass er wie eine art
reiches wunderkind dargestellt wurde
dass sein traum lebt obwohl er
eigentlich zeigen wollte dass sein
unternehmen hat gesund pflegt und in
dass er sein leben steckt
zwei jahre später verkaufte er das
unternehmen für 750 millionen dollar und
richtete seinen blick ganz woanders hin
michael kast ist emeritierter professor
für pädagogik city ich bekam einen anruf
von jemandem von dem ich noch nie gehört
hatte reed hastings der sagte er wolle
nach dem fortkommen und bildungspolitik
studieren ich war mir nicht ganz sicher
warum er daran interessiert war denn es
passte nicht zu seinem lebenslauf
[Musik]
sechs monate lang studierte er und
versuchte dann sich für eine neue art
von schule in kalifornien einzusetzen
und es gelang ihm eines der ersten
gesetze für schulen in freier
trägerschaft durchzusetzen dass
innovation und neue betreiber zuließ und
ein völlig neues konzept für kalifornien
war
[Musik]
auch für hastings gab es ein neues
konzept ist ein vorfall 1997 brachte ihn
dazu eine ganze branche neu zu erfinden
es erinnerte er sich 2005 an eine 40
dollar seines gebühren die er an einen
filmverleih teilen musste
ich weiß noch dass ich meiner frau
nichts davon erzählen wollte und dachte
rotor wird setze ich schon meine ehe
deswegen aufs spiel als er erzählte ich
natürlich sagen
dann dachte ich ich kann doch nicht der
einzige sein der mit solchen songs
gebühren zu kämpfen hat das tut dann
dachte ich über das internet und dvds
nacht darüber wie das auch ohne
funktionieren könnte
hastings die chance in einem neuen
format und einem überraschenden neuen
geschäft dvds per post aber zuerst
musste er herausfinden ob die scheiben
den postweg überleben würden also habe
ich einen haufen cds eingepackt die ford
escort aber nicht kaufen da habe sie
eigentlich selbst geschickt und musste
dann erst mal 24 stunden warten um zu
sehen ob sie ein stück
dann am nächsten tag
und ich riss die umschläge auf die erste
sehr gut aus beide seiten aus die dritte
sah gut aus und ich dachte mir dieser
blödsinn wird funktionieren
1998 startete hastings netflix flex als
erster online dvd verleih die wie die
der heutige redbox präsident mit war
einer der mitgründer
wir begannen in einem alten bankgebäude
unser inventar hatten wir in einem alten
tresorraum wir waren vielleicht sieben
acht leute und jeder wollte herausfinden
wie man das unterhaltungsgeschäft
umkrempeln könnte
sie deckten sich bei einzelhändlern wie
best buy mit dvds ein aber es gab ein
problem
kaum ein haushalt hatte einen
dvd-spieler
sie kosteten fast 600 dollar und niemand
wusste wann die billiger werden würden
er hatte alles auf die dvds gesetzt wenn
es die dvds nicht gegeben hätte für
einmal wäre nichts einfach null
[Musik]
beherrschten die branche mit tausenden
von einzelhandelsgeschäften fast überall
denn hastings konkurrenzfähig sein
wollte musste er sich etwas einfallen
lassen spears und er hatte eine idee die
ein einfach zu bedienendes
gegen eine monatliche gebühr konnten die
mitglieder so viele filme sehen wie sie
wollten ohne seines gebühren er erkannte
dass es keine gute idee ist den kunden
jedes mal eine rechnung über drei dollar
zu stellen also brachte er das
unternehmen dazu ein abo modell
einzuführen das hat alles verändert
diese veränderung wurde durch zwei neue
funktionen begünstigt die warteliste für
filme die benutzer sehen wollten und
computergenerierte empfehlungen die
erstaunlich genau waren michael peca
verfolgt netflix seit zehn jahren
der internet bestellen mechanismus war
innovativ die empfehlungsmaschine war
innovativ und die warteschlange war
innovativ netflix war schon sehr früh
erfolgreich weil sie die ersten waren
die all diese dinge herausgefunden haben
aber trotz aller innovationen war
netflix immer noch kaum auf dem radar
die einnahmen von fünf millionen euro
anfang 2000 verschwanden neben den 4,5
milliarden von dollars nahmen die 900
mal so groß waren wie netflix 6
in einem cleveren zug hastings auch
seinen größten konkurrenten zu alle
liebten blockbuster blockbuster war das
goldene kind und netflix war so etwas
wie das hässliche stiefkind dass da
jetzt kam und alle dachten nun das ding
wird nicht überleben dem werden keine
beine wachsen es wird sterben wir hatten
probleme kunden zu akquirieren und wir
sahen blockbuster als größte einzel
quelle für verleih kunden
also wandten wir uns an sie und luden
sie ein strategischer partner und
investor zu werden
der unterhaltungsriese von das
unterhaltsam
war geschäftsführer von
gedachten naja wenn wir in dieses
geschäft einsteigen sollten wir die
internetrechte wahrscheinlich nicht für
ein paar prozentpunkte an ein anderes
unternehmen abgegeben
deswegen mussten wir immer wider abwägen
ob wir einsteigen oder nicht
ich glaube netflix hatte großes glück
dass blockbuster der schlafende riese
nichts unternommen hat und sie schliefen
weiter david ist ein gentleman ich
glaube wenn man netflix einen anderen
chef gegeben hätte der ein bisschen
frecher und dreister gewesen wäre hätte
man blockbuster vielleicht dazu
provoziert zu konkurrieren
es gab keinen grund mit blockbuster zu
konkurrieren ende 2009 at flix in den
roten zahlen die verluste stiegen auf 57
millionen dollar es hörte sich einfach
an wie eine weitere dot com idee wie
ethos und die meisten investoren waren
einfach davon überzeugt dass netflix
eine kleine nischen idee war die leute
wollten kein abo es würde sich nie
durchsetzen
während netflix darum kämpfte profitabel
zu werden reed hastings wieder etwas
unerwartetes er nahm einen zusätzlichen
job in der staatlichen bildungsberatung
von kalifornien und jeder von ihnen hat
schon mal versucht große organisation zu
die erste hälfte der schlacht besteht
darin sie auf den richtigen kurs zu
bringen
wenn ich jemals in einem schützengraben
wäre hätte ich gerne reed hastings bei
mir denn wir würden über die nächsten
schulausschusssitzung diskutieren und
darüber wie die entscheidung ausfallen
sollte kann ich denn sobald eine
entscheidung gefallen war ging er da
rein und blieb standhaft und setzte die
reform durch
netflix dagegen war alles andere als
etabliert und ging in den dort kaum
sturzflug über wie sind die helden
gefallen und einer aktuellen studie von
morgan stanley die mutter hat die
durchschnittliche internet-aktie zwei
drittel von ihren 52 wochenhoch
eingebüßt
netflix hatte schon lange einen
börsengang geplant der markt in eine
abwärtsspirale
beim ersten versuch eines börsengangs
sahen wir uns mit vielen hindernissen
konfrontiert
die blase geplatzt man glaubte das
internetunternehmen keine substanz
hätten ein es gab die antrags angst gab
den elften september
es war ein desaster bei dem alles in die
falsche richtung lief
sagte den börsengang ab
und musste im oktober 2001 auf jeden
dritten mitarbeiter entlassen netflix
stand am rande der katastrophe
ich glaube netflix hätte zwischen 99 und
2002 jederzeit untergehen können wenn es
ernsthafte konkurrenz gegeben hätte als
das jahr zu ende ging kam dadurch
die preise für dvd-player vielen und
hastings legte fast jeder neuen box
einen gutschein für eine kostenlose
testversion von netflix bei das geschäft
lief gut
nachdem das unternehmen wieder auf kurs
war wurde der börsengang 2002
wirklichkeit in diversen netflix wintop
die netflix aktie stieg am ersten tag um
12 auf 16 dollar 75 aber es war ein
zweischneidiges schwert
beobachtet netflix als internetexperte
der
börsengang verschafft netflix viel
aufmerksamkeit nicht nur bei den
verbrauchern sondern auch bei den
konkurrenten und so wurde die konkurrenz
von unternehmen wie walmart und
etablierten anbietern wie blockbuster
immer größer
rheuma startete seinen konkurrierenden
dienst im jahr 2003 ein jahr später
stieg auch blockbuster in der nähe sind
anfangs ähnlich wie netflix er startet
nämlich mit einer kostenlosen test
mitgliedschaft eines der schönsten worte
in der amerikanischen sprache ist
kostenlos und das brachte uns ein
ordentliches wachstum
blockbuster nahm außerdem zwei euro
weniger an monatsgebühren was einem
hässlichen preiskrieg auslöste netflix
senkte den preis
blockbuster kontert er walmart unterbot
beide also gingen blockbuster noch
weiter runter bei einer telefonkonferenz
am ende des jahres erklärte hastings
blockbuster hat uns mit allen beworfen
außer mit der küchenspüle
ich und einige wichtige mitglieder des
managementteams saßen in meinem büro und
hörten der telefonkonferenz zur jemand
sagte warum schicken wenn nicht
der ganze tag haben wir eine verschickt
damit war die feindschaft natürlich in
beton gegossen
der harte wettbewerb forderte seinen
tribut
die netflix aktie stürzte um 75 prozent
der analyst michael pachter kommentierte
netflix sei ein wertloses stück scheiße
das von wirklich netten leuten geleitet
wird
ich war überzeugt dass blockbuster
effektiv konkurrenz machen würde und ich
dachte wenn blockbuster entschlossen war
seine kunden zu behalten dann würden at
flix verschwinden
hastings ging nicht kampflos
er opferte gewinne um die konkurrenz
zurück zu drängen und das wachstum
aufrechtzuerhalten
es wurde ein zermürbungskrieg
sie waren der meinung dass netflix nicht
in der lage sein würde so einen
wettbewerb zu überleben war und das
blockbuster und dann walmart
letztendlich nur noch die gewinne aus
netflix herauspressen würden und ich
glaube was beide unternehmen in ziemlich
kurzer zeit herausfinden war dieses
geschäft viel schwieriger als sie
dachten
während der kampf mit blockbuster und
walmart tobte erlitt hastings einem
persönlichen rückschlag vier jahre lang
hatte er sich im kalifornischen
bildungsministerium für eine schulreform
engagiert doch als er mehr zweisprachige
programme forderte warfen ihnen die
demokratischen abgeordneten raus es war
ein schlag für ihn bis kam überraschend
und es war sicher auch demütigend von
seiner eigenen politischen partei
abgelehnt zu werden
dies aber er sagte wenn das ein grund es
mich auf dem schulausschuss zu werfen
dann gehe ich stolz und erhobenen
hauptes
hastings konzentrierte sich auf den
kampf seines unternehmens an das dvd
versandgeschäft und mitte 2005 begann
sich das blatt zu wenden
war zog sich zurück und überließ netflix
eine leihe kunden im tausch gegen
verkaufs
blockbuster gewann zwar abonnenten
verlor aber hunderte von millionen
dollar nun war häftlings an der reihe in
jemanden als nett zu bezeichnen wir sind
nicht gegen bot basta das sind alles
nette leute wir wollen einen besseren
service anbieten und damit die kunden
uns vorziehen und das führt
gegebenenfalls dazu dass sie dichtmachen
2007 sagte and yoko auf dem sundance
filmfestival in utah dass er zu einem
treffen mit hastings eingeladen wurde um
über einen geht's hier hätte es lieber
gehabt dass netflix blockbuster online
kauft aber wir haben ihm eine fusion
es blieb beim gespräch weil es bedenken
wegen der kartellvorschriften gab
2008 war ein tier kurve
und blockbuster zog sich aus dem online
geschäft zurück sie haben hunderte von
millionen dollar verloren als sie
versuchten mit netflix zu konkurrieren
und dafür hatten sie einfach nicht das
geld man wusste dass sie irgendwann
aufgeben mussten und genau das ist dann
ja schließlich passiert es war ein
triumph für netflix hastings hatte sich
das geschäft mit den filmen per post
gesichert
2007 lieferte das unternehmen die
milliardste dvd aus
da war es schon dabei netflix mit einem
dienst neu zu erfinden er versprach die
dvd überflüssig zu machen video
streaming im internet das war es was er
von anfang an bei netflix vorausgesehen
hatte es dauerte nur ein jahrzehnt bis
es auch so eintraf wenn es etwas gibt
worauf man sich verlassen kann wenn das
die technologie die bandbreite immer
schneller und billiger macht die
bandbreite mark billiger gewesen sein
aber nicht die shows im gegensatz zu
dvds brauchte netflix für jeden
gestreamten film eine lizenz und die
gebühren waren astronomische andrew
williams team vom hollywood magazin
soweit
ich glaube die titel mit denen netflix
anfing waren wahrscheinlich der unterste
bodensatz das waren die filme oder
fernsehsendungen die schon lange
vergessen waren nicht die besten sachen
ich erinnere mich an eine spöttische
bemerkung und eine notiz darüber dass
niemand operation kleinhirn drei sehen
wollte als der film anfang der
neunzigerjahre rauskam
also wollten sie in 2007 sicher auch
nicht singen
selbst wenn sie es wollten netflix
konnte nur auf ein gerät streamen
nämlich den pc
wir sehen uns keine filme auf unserem pc
an wer streamt auf den pc wen
interessiert so was das war verrückt wir
dachten wirklich es sei verrückt also
tastings diesen service den abonnenten
kostenfrei an als er dann ankündigte wir
werden das kostenlos anbieten da waren
wir uns sicher dass er verrückt ist
er bemühte sich auch um mehr inhalte
fügte in weniger als zwei jahren 11.000
titel hinzu und sicherte sich einen
bahnbrechenden vertrag für erst
aufgeführte filme und serien muss ein
paar jahre zurückgehen zu dem deal den
sie mit stars abgeschlossen haben
dadurch bekam sie großartige filme aus
der sony bibliothek der disney
bibliothek und sie bekam den deal für
nur etwa 20 millionen dollar das war das
schnäppchen des jahrzehnts
es folgten deals mit vielen der großen
studios
es ist mir eine freude ihnen den netflix
ceo reed hastings vorzustellen noch
beeindruckender war wie schnell netflix
das streaming aufnahmegeräte ausweitete
ein enormer erfolg für uns und für fast
jedes unterhaltungssystem auf dem
planeten das wachstum hielt an
2011 erreichte die zahl der abonnenten
die 20 millionen marke ein umsatz von
über 2 milliarden dollar weckte die
aufmerksamkeit der branchen goliath
amazon apple google und facebook das
sind alles 800 pfund gorillas das könnte
gefährlich werden für netflix wenn ich
überlege ob es eine zeit gab in der sie
mehr druck ausgesetzt waren mir fällt
keine ein überraschender weise kam der
wirkliche druck nicht von diesen tag
gegangen
sondern von einer reihe eigener viel
entscheidung
im juli 2011 kündigte netflix an seine
abo gebühr um 60 prozent zu erhöhen
800.000 kunden liefen davon zwei monate
später entschuldigte sich hennings
reumütig wir machen dieses video heute
uns persönlich zu entschuldigen er
kündigte an dass netflix sein bvb und
streaming geschäft aufteilen würde die
preiserhöhung blieb aber aus die wie die
bei mail sollte eine neue marke werden
quick star der plan scheiterte auf
kunden und aktionäre flüchteten weiter
wollten abos und aktien loswerden
netflix nun in einer abwärtsspirale war
gezwungen einen rückzieher zu machen
netflix drückt heute den rückspiel knopf
das unternehmen macht eine große
kehrtwende und sagt quick star ist tot
und die dvd und streaming-dienste wieder
unter einem dach
der grund dafür ist einfach die kunden
mochten es einfach nicht hastings
entschuldigte sich erneut diesmal dafür
dass er zu schnell gehandelt hat
wurde zum symbol dafür dass netflix
nicht zugehört hat und wir haben den
kurs schnell geändert
erhalten an dvds als teil der netflix
burgfest
netflix verlor innerhalb von drei
monaten fast zwei drittel seines wertes
an einem tag seiten berauben de 23
milliarden und als ob das nicht schon
genug wäre trennten sich netflix und
stars netflix die neueren filme von
disney und sony vorenthielt und den
eindruck hinterließ netflix verliere
inhalte und erhöhe trotzdem die preise
neue vereinbarungen
er habe nie daran gedacht zurückzutreten
und nicht an den fehlern
die wir alle über den konsum von
unterhaltung denken verändert er hat die
möglichkeiten wie man filme bekommt
erweitert
schreiben sie kennen ihre
herausforderungen versteckten sich nicht
es gibt nur sehr wenige unternehmen die
so viele dinge getan haben und damit
erfolg haben und
wissen sie zwölf jahre später ist es
wieder eines dieser unternehmen dass man
vielleicht nicht mag aber
nicht streiten kann
[Musik]
richard branson der mann mit dem
goldenen händchen und dem milliardär
fläche
er ist sagenhaft reich berühmt wie ein
rockstar und scheint sich immer gut zu
amüsieren
bin ich habe riesiges glück gehabt ich
habe jede minute meines lebens genossen
ich würde mit niemandem tauschen wollen
reichtum beeindruckt ihn nicht ihm geht
es eher um die frage habe ich spaß man
braucht ein gleichgewicht grenzen hat
einen sexy namen virgin in marken gold
verwandelt mit über 300 waren und
dienstleistungen von rock über
flugreisen bis hin zu handys und zügen
wir haben es mit den fetten unternehmen
aufgenommen kam nicht wirklich viel über
den verbraucher nachgedacht haben und
wir sind hin und haben sie aufgerüttelt
wenn man die risiken analysieren würde
die er eingegangen ist würde man nicht
mitmachen denn keine risikoanalyse würde
sagen mach weiter so um alles über
wasser zu halten wurde branson zu seinem
eigenen besten werber indem er abenteuer
und spaß auslebte und dafür sein eigenes
leben aufs spiel setze ich habe
vermutlich fast keine gelegenheit
ausgelassen um zu versuchen mich
umzubringen und ich habe das große glück
heute hier zu sein über diese
geschichten zu sprechen wenn es so einen
titel gäbe wäre richard branson
vielleicht wirklich der interessanteste
mann der welt
besitzt eine eigene insel fliegt mit
ballons um den globus arbeitet mit den
großen der welt zusammen und plant ein
virgin niveau zum unerforschten
meeresgrund zu bringen die außen vor
sein bisheriges kannte es das abenteuer
man lebt nur einmal und wir akzeptieren
dass es mit risiken verbunden ist etwas
zu tun was die menschheit noch nicht
getan hat aber wir tun es mit offenen
augen
bremsen verbrachte einen großteil seines
lebens auf dem hochseil des
unternehmerischen risikos gehäufte ein
vermögen von mehr als vier milliarden
dollar
ich war nie daran interessiert geld zu
verdienen habe ich meine viele leute
werden sagen das ist leicht zu sagen wie
viel geld gemacht hat aber ich war
einfach daran interessiert dinge zu
schaffen dinge auf die sie stolz sein
kann und eine menge spaß dabei zu haben
ritschel charles nicolas prinzen wurde
am 18 juli 1950 am stadtrand von london
geboren märz in london sein vater war
rechtsanwalt seine mutter eine ehemalige
flugbegleiterin als schwerer
legastheniker konnte er im alter von
acht jahren kaum lesen und war mit
zahlen hoffnungslos überfordert es ist
ein fall die schule war schmerzhaft die
schaute auf eine tafel mein verstand
nichts
interessanterweise wenn man sich die
geschichten von legasthenikern anguckt
schneiden sie oft ganz besonders gut ab
weil er sich auf die bereiche
konzentrieren in denen
sie lernen sich ja sehr schulsachen zu
delegieren mit paul war der engste
freund und später geschäftspartner von
benson
ich habe bei richie hat immer gedacht er
wird die welt verändert man konnte schon
früh erkennen dass er qualitäten hatte
die unter all den anderen freunden die
wir hatten nicht üblich waren wir
machten immer mutproben saßen auf beiden
seiten der weißen linie und es ging
darum wer sich als letzter bewegt wenn
das auto die straße runter kommt richard
gewann immer
aber grenzen hatte eine starke
unternehmerische ader mit 13 versuchte
er weihnachtsbäume zu verkaufen er
versuchte sittiche zu züchten
mit 15 beschloss er eine nationale
studentenzeitung zu gründen ich
arbeitete von einer telefonzelle an der
schule aus rief coca cola anrief leute
an ob sie für die zeitschrift schreiben
wollen rief die barclays bank an ob sie
eine anzeige schalten wir gehen diese
schlangen von leuten vor der
telefonzelle sich noch mehr geld ein war
die zeitschrift c't juden zwar eine
sofortige erfolg mit einer auflage von
50.000 stück graham
reisereporter für den landen telegraph
und berichtete über 20 jahre lang über
grenzen
obwohl ein kind der 60er jahre war weil
man etwas unbeholfen ich glaube was
passierte war dass das unternehmen einen
wortschatz seine tiefe gab und von da an
ging es weiter
1970 gründete grenzen einen
versandhandel für discount platten mit
dem erhofften geld für die zeitschrift
zu bekommen die erste aufgabe bestand
darin einen namen zu finden summer jazz
dance jemand schlug slip des treckers
vorbei und wir hatten alte vinyl platten
die immer wieder verrutschten und jemand
anderes lacht für weißt du warum nicht
welchen wir sind doch alle jungfrauen
ich dachte plötzlich ich bin nun frau im
geschäft weiß durch ich könnte auch in
anderen dingen eine jungfrau sein also
warum nicht welchen
ein post streik brachte den platten
versands 1971 fast zum erliegen
branson beschloss einen plattenladen zu
eröffnen eine mit kopfhörern und wasser
kissen der sich an jüngere leute richard
bransons cousin war sein erster
plattenkäufer und der spätere leiter von
virgin records alle wurden gleich
bezahlt so dass man das gefühl hatte
niemand darf mehr geld verdienen als die
anderen aber wenn man mal darüber
nachdenkt war es eigentlich ganz
praktisch denn so konnte man allen
weniger zahlen
einige der leute die für richard in den
plattenläden in notting hill gearbeitet
haben haben platten gestohlen und sie
waren total erstaunt als richards sie
wegen diebstahls gefeuert hat er war vom
ersten tag an darauf getrimmt ein
geschäftsmann
fünf monate nach der eröffnung des
ladens wurde bremsen plötzlich wegen
steuerhinterziehung verhaftet
er hatte seine platten zum teil billiger
angeboten weil er einen weg gefunden
hatte die schallplatten steuer zu
umgehen
er verbrachte eine nacht im gefängnis
und seine eltern mussten ihr haus
beleihen um ihn rauszuholen
er dachte um mitmischen zu können müsste
er steuern umgehen das muss ein großer
schock für ihn gewesen sein er war
extrem verärgert aber er hat sich
tadellos verhalten niemand sonst bekam
irgendwelche strafen
ich hatte es geschafft ein
strafrechtliches verfahren zu vermeiden
indem er bezahlt was verlangt wurde und
wir haben unsere plattenläden sehr
schnell erweitert so dass wir den umsatz
hatten um die schulden abzubezahlen
seitdem habe ich dafür gesorgt dass
alles sauber damit wir uns keine sorgen
machen mussten dass jemand an die tür
klopft
um 150.000 dollar bußgeld zu begleichen
an einen gerichtsprozess oder sogar eine
haftstrafe zu umgehen gründete branson
ein aufnahmestudio und ein neues
plattenlabel
erster vertragspartner war ein
unbekannter folkloristen mike oldfield
mit einem seltsamen instrumental album
namens tubular bells
wir haben uns gefragt ob wir wetten
sollten wie oft sich dieses album wohl
verkaufen würde ich dachte vielleicht
20.000 mal was mir zu der zeit viel
erschien abermillionen später sie wissen
schon eine ganz andere geschichte 16
millionen um genau zu sein über nacht
machte die platte virgin bekannt
und richard branson noch nicht ganz 23
zum millionär bremsen steckte all seine
gewinne in neue künstler und unternehmen
aber das verunsicherte seine partner
paul leistete so viel widerstand das
bremsen ihn aus seite ich glaube nicht
dass wir genug cash flow hatten um das
geschäft weiter so expandieren zu können
und ich lag falsch ich bin vielleicht
bereit mehr einzusetzen als ich anderen
leuten raten würde es gibt fälle wo ich
meine frau dazu gebracht habe ein papier
zu unterschreiben und sie haben nicht
gemerkt dass das haus für dieses
geschäft aufs spiel gesetzt wird
1984 lebte richard branson das leben
eines rock'n'roll königs ihm gehörte
diese insel auf den britischen
jungferninseln
und virgin records war eines der
erfolgreichsten unabhängigen labels der
welt
des sex pistols simple minds human
league culture club wahren
verkaufsschlager
branson war reich und wollte das geld
ausgeben aus heiterem himmel rief ein
versicherungs anwalt namens randolph
fields an und bat grenzen um hilfe bei
einer transatlantischen fluggesellschaft
diamond trade meine anderen am partner
rauften sich die haare weil ich
plötzlich sagte wisst ihr was ich hasse
es mit den airlines anderer leute zu
reisen und wir können das besser machen
meine anteile die ich damals besaß 15
prozent der gesamten virgin group wurden
ziemlich wertvoll also war ich entsetzt
und sagte das ist der anfang vom ende
unserer beziehung
prinzen startete seine fluggesellschaft
mit einer gebrauchten 747 der von boeing
liest verkehr von boeing sagte das
unternehmen noch
wir sind die leute die in die sex
pistols und die rolling stones gebracht
haben
sagte scherzhaft nun an einem solchen
namen hoffen wir mal dass das was wird
wir werden es versuchen
[Musik]
nachdem er viel heraus gekauft hatte
beschloss branson eine bessere mischung
aus economy und business class tarifen
anzubieten wurde wobei der schwerpunkt
auf nonstop spaß lag
der eröffnungs flug von london nach new
york new york gab den ton an
ich kann ihnen sagen das war eine orgie
es war wild es wurde getrunken wir waren
oben ohne models in flugzeugen ist
einfach eine party und wirtschaft gab
den ton an
david haye die erste person die branson
einstellte war eine führungskraft bei
virgin atlantic ohne tor die erst als
ich die tür des flugzeugs im new yorker
öffnete war dass wir in champagner
korken aus der flasche contest ich
glaube es wurde nie so viel champagner
getrunken wie auf diesem parcours
mit nur einem flugzeug und einer strecke
war bransons erstes problem die werbe
und promotion er hatte nicht das
werbebudget um mit british airways und
in anderen riesigen fluggesellschaften
zu konkurrieren also nahm er die sache
selbst in die hand und begann eine reihe
atemberaubender ballon & boat trip
virgin airlines schnell bekannt machen
sollte haushoch dieses der beginn eines
großen abenteuers sein flug über den
atlantik
1987 faszinierte die medien wochenlang
fünf menschen waren bei früheren
versuchen ums leben gekommen berlins
trend war bremsens co pilot
belegte sein leben ganz in meine hände
und ich musste auf ihn aufpassen
als sie die irische see erreichten sie
schleuderten heftige winde den ballon
gegen die wellen
ein partner der mehr erfahrung mit
ballonfahren hatte sprang aus dem ballon
echte blieb allein zurück und der ballon
stieg auf 10 15.000 fuß
ich war im wasser ridge im ballon und er
wusste nicht wirklich wie das
funktioniert ich hatte noch nie so viel
angst in meinem leben
grenzen schaffte es den ballon
herunterzuholen und sprang ins eiskalte
wasser
ein hubschrauber der luftstreitkräfte
wollte ihm zusammen mit peer heraus der
nach zwei stunden schwimmen fast
gestorben war
richard ist eine mischung aus live
niveau und ted turner er würde ja sagen
ich fahre mit dem ballon weil es gute
werbung für die firma ist
aber tut das weil es ihm spaß macht wenn
er eine katze wäre wäre er schon beim
dritten set von neun leben ende 1989
vergrößerte sich richard bransons welt
an allen fronten er heiratete seine
langjährige partnerin john tempelmann
auf necker island
das paar hatte schon zwei kinder den
vierjährigen sam und die achtjährige
rolli auch das unternehmen expandierte
grenzen hatte die virgin group 1986 an
die börse gebracht was mehr als 56
millionen dollar einbrachte
ich glaube nicht dass ein börsengang die
art wie wir unsere geschäftig führen
sehr verändern wird das erwies sich als
falsch es machte sehr wohl einen
unterschied bremsen verabscheute es
seinem aufsichtsrat rechenschaft
abzulegen und kaufte virgin zurück nun
lenkte er ein kleines aber prekäres
imperium mit einer airline die ständig
gefahr lief unterzugehen auf gründer und
schlimmer noch british airways war
entschlossen seinen aufstrebenden
rivalen zu vernichten
die rivalität zwischen british airways
und virgin atlantic war mir immer ein
rätsel
ich glaube es lag am britischen
establishments
sie sahen diesen jungen rücksichtslosen
emporkömmlings langen haaren das hat sie
einfach recht verärgert
so sehr dass british airways 1991 etwas
startete das die presse als kampagne der
schmutzigen tricks bezeichnete
team sind sie hatten teams hinter
verschlossenen türen die sich illegal
zugang zu unseren computer daten
verschafften ihre anliegen vorgaben von
virgin atlantic zu sein wir hatten flüge
gestrichen und suchten sie auch würdig
erweisen sie haben leute die meine
müller einmal durchsuchte mülleimer
unserer klubs durchsuchten irgendeinen
schmutz über uns zu finden sie
platzierten stories in der presse
und das schlimmste branson war überzeugt
dass british airways gerüchte schürze
virgin sei insolvent und stehe kurz vor
dem untergang
von virgin galactic und arbeitet seit
1987 eng mit branson zusammen jeden tag
an dem du mit leeren sitzen ab herbst
verlierst du geld wenn also jemand
passagiere davon überzeugt nicht bei
einer bestimmten airline zu buchen weil
sie glauben dass sie pleite geht dann
wird sie pleite gehen branson kämpfte
darum virgin atlantic am leben zu
erhalten und wieder einmal setzte er
dafür sein leben aufs spiel tut er
startete zu einer weiteren gefährlichen
ballonfahrt dieses mal über den pazifik
mitten über dem pazifik verloren wir
zwei volle treibstofftanks und wir
wussten nicht ob wir noch genug haben um
es zu schaffen
wir mussten diesen ballon mit einer
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von über
180 meilen pro stunde pflegen wir wurden
ja nur vom wind angetrieben also waren
nicht chancentod zahl gering
aber dann kamen wir genau den kern des
jetstreams und sahen plötzlich wie der
geschwindigkeitsmesser stieg von 160 170
180 190 200 210 220
ich bin kein religiöser mensch alles war
als ob jemand da oben diesen ballon
genommen und angeschoben hätte mitten
durch den jetstream
branson und linz trend stürzen über
einem zugefrorenen see 300 meilen von
nächsten wohnort entfernt wir verfehlten
unser ziel um dreieinhalb tausend meilen
und landeten in der arktis in einem
schneesturm bei minus 60 grad aber wir
hätten nicht glücklicher sein können in
dem moment als branson ausstieg so war
er tatsächlich schon ein superstar auch
sein plattenlabel lief heiß virgin
records nahm janet jackson und die
rolling stones unter vertrag
aber die schmutzkampagne von british
airways gegen virgin atlantic machte es
unmöglich kredite zu bekommen und die
airline zu retten musste bremsen die
härteste entscheidung seines lebens
treffen er beschloss seine geliebte
plattenfirma zu verkaufen penny peck war
31 jahre lang seine persönliche
assistentin jeder war furchtbar
geschockt ich meine wichert war noch
geschockte als alle anderen und er
weinte und weinte und weinte es war als
würde man ein kind verkaufen sagt es dem
personal tragen tränen aus rannte zurück
zu meinem haus und kam an diesem schild
vorbei auf dem stand im prinzen verkauft
für eine milliarde dollar an
mir wurde klar dass das leben kann nicht
so schlecht waren er hat die zukunft von
virgin atlantic gesichert weil er danach
genug kapital hatte um jedem
konkurrenten ins gesicht schauen und
sagen zu können weißt du was ich kann
das genauso lange aussetzen wie du
die leute sagten damals wir seien
verrückt die plattenfirmen zu verkaufen
das geld in eine airline zu stecken aber
später ist die plattenindustrie riaa
zusammengebrochen und die flugindustrie
hat sich nicht so schlecht für uns
entwickelt einen monat nach dem
milliardenschweren deal verklagte
branson british airways wegen
verleumdung die fluggesellschaft einigte
sich außergerichtlich und zahlte 1,1
millionen dollar
wir haben den höchsten schadenersatz
einer verleumdungs fälle gewonnen und
sie mussten sich öffentlich
entschuldigen
[Musik]
richard branson war überglücklich dieser
tag war wahrscheinlich einer der
großartigsten seiner karriere er hatte
es geschafft er hat die mächtige british
airways zertreten
an diesem abend telefonierte er mit
verschiedenen leuten und er hatte diese
entschlossenheit in seiner stimme das
war der moment er wollte virgin atlantic
zu einem weltweiten erfolg machen er
wollte es nehmen und es auf der ganzen
welt ausbauen
nachdem er 1992 virgin records für eine
milliarde dollar verkauft hatte bei
richard branson bereit sein wertvollstes
gut zu verwerten die marke wird in
mainz wurde plötzlich klar dass wir
etwas haben das für schützen und pflegen
müssen die marke ist letztlich das worum
es bei virgin geht
branson war die marke und er hat sie
unermüdlich gefördert bis heute hat er
über 300 produkte und dienstleistungen
wird imitiert ich glaube wenn man etwas
schafft auf das man stolz sein kann dann
wird es wahrscheinlich erfolgreich sein
aber sind denke ich dachte nicht los wir
bringen diese marke jetzt in alle
möglichen bereiche ich dachte man könnte
es mit fitnessstudios probieren oder mit
dem mobilfunkgeschäft
einige versuche wie virgin und virgin
cola verpufften schnell
virgin trains startete stoppen
die infrastruktur war marode
und es dauerte jahre bis die züge
pünktlich vor
aber andere vorstöße hatten
atemberaubenden erfolg
1999 stieß bremsen auf eine goldader er
schloss sich mit dienstleistern zusammen
um virgin mobile zu gründen sie
lieferten das netz er das marketing und
den namen
sowie die innovative idee die kunden
während der fahrt bezahlen zu lassen wer
chips professor an der school of
business der columbia university ist
experte für markenbildung der wert einer
marke liegt wirklich in den
immateriellen werten kunden kaufen nicht
nur produkte sie kaufen nicht nur
funktionalität sie kaufen auch ein image
sie kaufen einen lebensstil sie kaufen
eine erfahrung er steht für bestimmte
dinge er steht für service für kunden
erlebnis für innovation für spaß
branson war jetzt der business könig
1999 wurde er vom königshaus seines
landes geehrt die königin schlug ihn zum
ritter als ikone des milleniums für
seinen beitrag zum handeln
[Musik]
wohin dar fünf jahre später brachte er
virgin mobile an die börse nach eigenen
angaben wurde das unternehmen mit 15
milliarden dollar bewertet
[Musik]
jedes unternehmen der virgin group
bleibt unabhängig
so dass kein misserfolg das imperium zu
fall bringen kann trotzdem stellen
analysten regelmäßig den wert der virgin
group in frage die sich immer noch in
privater hand befindet die schlagzeilen
lauten wann wird bransons ballon platzen
jedes mal wenn wir etwas neues starteten
er strapaziert die marke zu sehr und
manchmal sagen sie weit daneben die
virgin group gründete immer wieder neue
unternehmen
2004 kündigte branson eines seiner
fantasievollsten an
er will menschen ins weltall bringen
angefangen bei seiner eigenen mutter ich
glaube wir stehen 18 monate vor dem
start ins all und ist damit vor dem
beginn eines völlig neuen bereich der
kommerziellen raumfahrt
hoffentlich werden hunderte wenn nicht
tausende von menschen die möglichkeit
haben astronaut zu werden und ins all zu
fliegen
es ist ein enormes risiko es ist als
würde man seinen namen seine marke auf
ein formel 1 rennwagen setzen es ist
toll wenn er gewinnt aber wenn er sich
irgendwo mein beton nospickel hat das
eine menge nachteile bremsen diente die
marke virgin 2006 noch weiter aus 6 da
seine airline tonnen von co2 in die
atmosphäre spucken
verpflichtete er sich alle gewinne
seiner transportunternehmen in den
nächsten zehn jahren ungefähr 3
milliarden dollar in die forschung für
einen umweltfreundlichen biokraftstoff
zu investieren
und er rief den ältestenrat ins leben
ein kriseninterventionsteam team unter
der leitung von nelson mandela
55 jahre alt hatte gutes geld verdient
und konnte so gut wie jeden anrufen und
dinge durchsetzen plötzlich war ich in
einer situation in der ich vielleicht
etwas in der welt bewirken konnte
kritiker machten sich über den neuen
sozialen branson lustig und verwiesen
auf die offshore steuer oder die er seit
jahren nutzt um sein vermögen zu
schützen ich glaube nicht dass richards
sich von den anderen sehr reichen
geschäftsleuten unterscheidet er hat
heerscharen von buchhaltern und anwälten
die ihm sagen wir wissen wo sie ihr geld
verstecken können ist
eher der unternehmer des volkes nur bis
zu einem gewissen punkt branson war
nicht in der lage sein gesamtes vermögen
zu schützen virgin america hatte einen
schweren start und verlor fast 400
millionen dollar bevor es im dritten
quartal 2010 begann gewinn zu machen
mit anfang 60 der virgin könig eine
lange und aufregende reise hinter sich
branson hat sich sein glück selbst
erarbeitet er war sehr sehr gut darin es
ist nicht nur ein goldenes händchen er
hat dafür gearbeitet
natürlich treibt ihm das geld an aber
reichtum beeindruckte ihn nicht sondern
eher die frage habe ich spaß habe ich
aufregung man braucht ein gleichgewicht
in exten reformen ich hatte
außerordentliches glück ich habe jede
minute meines lebens genossen in zukunft
werde ich die meiste zeit damit
verbringen gemeinnützige unternehmen zu
gründen und sie dabei zu beobachten wie
sie einige der großen probleme der welt
angeht aber gleichzeitig werden wir
immer noch wunderbare abenteuer erleben
wir werden in den weltraum fliegen auf
den grund der ozeane gehen und uns immer
noch anstrengend meine kinder und die
menschen um mich herum herausfordert und
eine menge spaß haben
die einstellung ist wenn du gegen mich
antreten willst dann sei bereits erklärt
zu werden larry ellison startete
oracle-software vor über 30 jahren und
das machte ihn zum bestbezahlten manager
der letzten zehn jahre geld mit einer
vergütung von 1,84 milliarden dollar
niemand konnte wie larry einen kunden
glauben machen mit seinen produkten
geschäftsleben verändern könnte er sieht
schon um die ecke lange bevor andere das
ende der strafe erreichen
die deutsche software firma wurde
verurteilt oracle 1,3 milliarden dollar
zu zahlen oder auf dem meer besteht kein
zweifel dass er es hasst sich
die technologie seines unternehmens
wurde zum rückgrat der weltweiten
informationssysteme von der regierung
bis zum online handels
der dreiste milliardär ist ein
ehrgeiziger provokateur mit einem
einzigartigen führungsstil
geplante oracle lautet wahrscheinlich
ist bekanntlich auch weiterführen wenn
ich einen meter achtzig unter der erde
liegen ist
[Applaus]
es wahrscheinlich ungefähr dass ich habe
einen lukas ist schnellste auto gerollt
dieses haus kostet 200 millionen dollar
das schnellste segelboot das jemals
gebaut wurde ich bin süchtig danach zu
gewinnen er ist ein adrenalin-junkie und
ein kompromissloser sammler von teurem
spielzeug
2010 gab er 400 millionen dollar aus um
den america s cup die älteste
sporttrophäe zum ersten mal seit 15
jahren wieder nach amerika zu
aber die wurzeln seines erfolges sind
sehr viel weniger einige der weltweit
wichtigsten software tools von denen sie
wahrscheinlich gar nicht wissen was
seine firma zu laufen drews company men
at work ist
jeder auf der welt benutzt sie wissen
ist bei allen möglichen transaktionen
fast jeder regierung der welt
jeder geschäftlichen transaktionen mit
fast jedem traditionellen oder internet
unternehmen der welt showbusiness er sie
eine kreditkarte haben weil sie ein
handy haben werden sie eines der
modernsten dinge des lebens haben
larry ellison hat wohl die wichtigste
computer software entwickelt von der sie
je gehört habe er war der mann hinter
der riesigen veränderung unserer
lebensweise
blieb im hintergrund seit wir versuchten
ihn für die teilnahme an diesem programm
zu gewinnen
1944 in der bronx geboren er wuchs
ellison in chicago auf
warum sollte sein vater ihn mit einer
nachricht mein dad sagte kurz vor dem
abendessen ach übrigens du bist
adoptiert und heute abend essen wir
hackbrett es war so schockierend
ich habe es einfach verdrängt und
jahrelang darüber nachgedacht ohne mich
wirklich damit zu konfrontieren
ein mittelmäßiger schüler musste die
formale bildung
ist redakteur für die sankt petersburger
times und hat erlassen für seine
biografie interviewt wollte keine regeln
befolgen weder eine schule in der
familie
er musste aus dem schatten von lewis
ellison hervorkommen und seinem vater
beweisen dass er etwas aus sich machen
konnte
sein gespür für die überholspur
offenbarte sich früh larry king los und
kaufte sich ein türkis blauen van de
boer da war ein stylischer typ wollte
die leute beeindrucken stiegen dieses
auto und fuhr nach kalifornien
larry ellison hatte viel potenzial
seine reise nach kalifornien spielte
eine große rolle dabei wer werden würde
alison kam nach berg und verdiente sich
seinen lebensunterhalt als programmierer
1973 arbeitete er beim computer
elektronik hersteller mdl dort lernte er
stewart regan kennen der sie sind seit
über 35 jahren befreundet an meinem
ersten arbeitstag ging hier meine kabine
und auch der anderen seite des flurs
stand ein paar typen ihm nie zur arbeit
erschienen sie redeten die ganze zeit
nur und einer von ihnen redete nur über
sich selbst
da war sie dumm alle anderen waren und
wie er eigentlich alles licon sollte
war ein talentierter aber ungeduldiger
programmierer der noch etwas suchte das
er selbst kontrollieren konnte zu sagen
er hätte die aufmerksamkeitsspanne eines
steppen läufers wäre übertrieben sie war
eher die eines blitzes
das änderte sich als er einen job bei
der firma mpeg 1 mpeg
sex hatte mit einem projekt zu kämpfen
das von der
es tut den code-namen oracle die sie
brauchte ein system zum speichern und
abrufen großer mengen ausländischer
geheimdienst informationen die sich auf
sensible operationen und illusionen
bezogen vorerst für allison war es die
aufgabe seines lebens und säte den samen
für seine zukunft in den 70er jahren
wurden daten noch auf magnetband
gespeichert
für die cia zu unbeständig
zu langsam er verließ apax und gründete
mit seinem freund kommt dem programm
youzhny bob miner seine eigene firma
[Musik]
das technische talent dagegen hatte die
fähigkeit zu verkaufen die vision
die fähigkeit zu einem kunden zu gehen
und zu erklären so kann sich ihr
geschäft verändern mit diesem
handgeschriebenes schild und 1200 dollar
gründeten sie software development
er sagte er würde eine art firma gründen
und ich dachte das ist die dümmste idee
von der ich je gehört habe denn larry
war nicht berühmt dafür dinge zu ende zu
bringen ich habe immer gesagt er ist
eine totale niete aus dem wird nie was
ich hatte halt recht ellisons neues
unternehmen brauchte ein produkt und
nachdem er eine obskure ibm
forschungsarbeit gelesen hatte glaubte
er es zu haben eine methode zum
sortieren von informationen dass die
allen bisherigen überlegen war kam bevor
eine relationale daten für gary blum der
14 jahre mit alison zusammenarbeitete
war das ein komplexer name aber eine
einfache idee relationale datenbank
größte stadt dieser größe ist eine
sammlung von daten und informationen sie
in ein format gebracht werden dass es
sehr einfach macht diese informationen
zu suchen und zu finden sie kommuniziert
ibm sei das potenzial ihrer
möglichkeiten nicht
ich sagte oh mein gott wir können ibm
auf den markt schlagen weil ibm nicht an
seine eigene idee glaubt er wissen
glaubte und bat gott mit dem
programmieren zu beginn wird für mich
ist es einfach eine coole technologien
macht spaß
die firma sei den markt wir waren uns
nicht sicher ob larry recht hatte aber
wir brauchten die
unternehmen dabei eine datenbank zu
erstellen dass sie die art wie
unternehmen daten abrufen und verwalten
drei zimmer und ein kleiner lobby
bereich wir waren zu viert und schrieben
programme larry war damit beschäftigt
kunden zu finden und das war irgendwie
bizarr weise keine software hatten
also alles was sie in büchern lesen über
jemanden der ein anführer ist ja war es
nicht aber er war hartnäckig
neue kohle- und wurde zum wichtigsten
botschaft hat das unternehmen
niemand hat besser auf geschäftsmann
gemacht
er konnte kunden davon überzeugen dass
er mit seinem produkt im geschäftsleben
verändern würde
doch für das weltweite geheimdienst
management brauchten sie immer noch eine
intelligentere lösung
verkaufte seine datenbank an diese
seinen ersten kunden und nannte die neue
software version 2 es gab keine version
1 weil alle dachten naja das kauft doch
niemand also haben wir mit version 2
angefangen sie war mindestens so viele
hd version 1 von irgendjemand sonst ich
nannte sie das kakerlaken hotel der
daten weisen die daten rein mit kamen
aber nicht mehr raus 1982 nahm ellison
den namen oracle auch für sein
unternehmen
erzielte auch seine sehr eigene weise
auf regierungsbehörden und große
unternehmen hat und ich erinnere mich
dass er mir sehr deutlich sagte wir
können nicht erfolgreich sein wenn wir
die kunden nicht an irgendeinem grund
erzählte larry der bank of america dass
wir 15 leute waren obwohl wir fünf waren
ich war mir nicht sicher warum die bank
an das von einem denken sollte wenn man
15 statt fünf ist barre larry hat ihnen
eine zahl gegeben die nicht stimmten
die auf einer japan reise in den frühen
70er jahren
ich habe dort mit einem geschäftsführer
gesprochen und er sagte das problem mit
amerika ist dass wir einfach keinen sinn
für wettbewerb haben
in japan glauben wir dass unsere
konkurrenten unseren kindern den reis
aus dem mund stehen und wir glauben dass
weniger als 100 prozent marktanteil
nicht ausreichend seien gehe über
leichen ansatz und wurde bekam der
onkel war bis mitte der 80er einfach mit
allen mitteln zu gewinnen
die einstellung ist wenn du gegen mich
antreten willst dann sei bereit
zerquetscht zu werden oder tritt nicht
gegen mittag
will oracle datenbank hob in einer
seiner anzeigen ab wie ein düsenjäger
bisher und 1986 ging oracle und die
börse 29 und 30 prozentiger anteil am
unternehmen war beeindruckende 93
millionen dollar wert die arge
börsengang war ein riesenerfolg wurde
aber schon am nächsten tag von
microsofts börsengang überschattet der
bill gates seinen glanz von 350
millionen einbrachte
1989 zu wissen mit oracle auf
siebenkampfes shores kalifornien der als
marken stadt gekämpft wurde eine
anspielung auf den zauberer von oz und
jeder wusste wer der zauberer war
weil sich einen ferrari 348 bestellt den
ersten davon in kalifornien haben wollte
aber stellte larry ein und irgendwo an
der ostküste und ließ ihn verschicken
bevor ich mein bekam er wollte nicht der
zweite sein da wollte der erste sein
seine besessenheit geerbte zu sein
forderten ihren tribut oracle schlug
gegen eine wand dieser aggressiven
verkaufspraktiken fing an echte probleme
zu machen diese aggressiven
verkaufspraktiken in den 80er jahren
machte das unternehmen zum alptraum der
buchhalter die vertriebsmitarbeiter
waren so aggressiv und heißt er auch
deals abzuschließen und gleichzeitig gab
es so wenig geschäftliche kontrolle
irgendwann bekamen wir das problem dass
wir schlechte verträge unterschrieben
haben sie verkaufen auch produkte die es
noch gar nicht
phillip futures verkauft sein man nimmt
eine menge geld einen machtgewinn mit
dingen die erst noch kommen
und dann stellt sich die frage wenn du
endlich liefern kannst ist an wen
verkaufst du hast es ja schon jedem
verkauf ist und zwar drei jahre bevor du
ins herz ist und dazu kam dass das
neueste produkt einen blindgänger fahrer
war voller schwachstellen die kunden
waren frustriert
wird manchmal als die nahtoderfahrung
von
wir haben kein fett abgeschnitten
sondern muskelmasse und in einigen
fällen könnte man sogar sagen wir
schnitten ein paar gliedmaßen ab
mit dem freien fall des aktienkurses
schrumpft
bis zum ersten november 1990 hatte er
790 millionen dollar verloren
[Musik]
dabei zu scheitern
larry hat versucht groß zu werden er
arbeitete die ganze zeit
war furchtbar für
wir sind ein haufen kinder die mit dem
geschäft aufgewachsen sind waren keine
kinder mehr als das geschäft war kein
kleines geschäft märz es war jetzt groß
und wir mussten fast die gesamte
geschäftsleitung ersetzen das war ein
sehr schmerzhafter prozess
in das unternehmen einzusteigen
er brachte das mit was ich als operative
disziplin bezeichnet wurde die erfahrung
die ein großes unternehmen los war
chaotisch schmerzhaft das wollte keiner
noch mal durchmachen
und so wurde irgendwie alles auf null
gesetzt der wahre dritter des
unternehmens kam jedoch in form eines
neuen produkts
der jüngste marketing
oracle 7 war ein spektakuläres produkt
viel die zukunft sei wieder rosiger aus
und ich glaube jeder bei oracle wusste
dass damals und konnte spüren
ellisons firma war der nahtoderfahrung
1994 überstiegen die einnahmen von
oracle die zwei milliarden dollar marke
die aktien waren fast drei milliarden
dollar wert
dafür ließen war das noch lange nicht
genug ohne das software schwergewicht zu
werden musste ließen den kampf mit dem
champion aufnehmen spiel
erschien persönlich enttäuscht zu sein
dass er nicht reicher war als bill gates
wenn du nicht die nummer eins fast wenn
du nicht der reichste was dran warst du
nicht an der spitze du warst nicht der
beste dallas verlor
ich denke dass larry dachte dass er in
einem riesigen wettbewerb mit bill gates
stand gates selbst hatte das vielleicht
gar nicht so gesehen
wollte als der größte innovator und
verkäufer in der software welt anerkannt
werde
er hatte einen harten kampf gegen den
typen der seine software praktisch sind
jeden einzelnen pc der welt eingebaut
hatte
[Musik]
worauf gates fixiert später gab er
öffentlich zu privatdetektive angestellt
zu haben über ihn auszugraben gays neues
produkt windows 95 begeisterte die
gesamte deckung gesehen und auch bei
diesem auftritt
dieses windows 95 ist eine enorm
komplizierte software und dass die leute
das in ihren haushalten installieren und
managen sollten finde ich ein bisschen
komisch ich meine es wird zeit für etwas
das leichter zu bedienen ist das ist
teil unserer strategie microsoft
anzugreifen aber es bringt nichts da zb
geld zu werfen oder ihn zu beneiden man
muss über produkte nachdenken und
produkte entwickeln die besser sind als
die die microsoft verkauft
erlassen machte einen schritt in den
markt für verbraucher geräte
er brachte den computer mit großem
getöse auf den markt die computer die
derzeit herrscht sind ziemlich teuer und
sehr komplex also haben wir diesen neuen
klassischen computer geführt sehr leicht
kostet sehr wenig jetzt kann jeder einen
computer benutzen bei der
kostengünstigen gleich zu bedienen ist
und
er sagte er wird
sozusagen eine art internet
ich kann mich an ein gespräch mit ihm
erinnern indem er sagte weißt du das
internet macht es möglich sich auf jedem
desktop eine welt vorzustellen
und das war die geburtsstunde des
ncr versuchte sein baby mit einer
kampagne voranzubringen und machte sich
über den beliebten pc luftig
ich hasse den pc oder stellt das zeug
doch ins netz
gehören nicht in pappe und auf den rest
wollen
dann muss ich hin und - zurückholen das
ist verrückt ich
liebe das internet
doch als die pc preise fielen war auch
der sc zum scheitern verurteilt
ich glaube nicht dass an der idee etwas
falsch war ich glaube es war bloß zu
früh und jahre später hätten wir die
welt erobern
und was haben die pc hersteller
gemacht
haben einen 500 dollar bisher entwickelt
der super im internet surft und e mails
bearbeitet
auf dem verbraucher sein sv war seiner
zeit zu weit voraus aber seine vision
von internet immer noch genau richtig
oracle datenbank wurde zur grundlage all
der internet dienste die für uns heute
selbstverständlich sind
die speichern informationen rufen
information ab und liefern informationen
über die oracle daten
die leute dachten larry sei verrückt
und es löste das größte problem der
geschichte im jahr 2000 gehörte larry
ellisons unternehmen zudem elite tech
unternehmen der welt
dabei interne kämpfe verdrängten bald
den geschäftsführer
der zum zweiten kommandeur und
thronfolger aufgestellten war
er beschrieb die kultur des unternehmens
das er verlassen hat es reicht nicht
wenn ein verkäufer seine quote erfüllte
er musste 200 prozent seiner quote
erfüllen die obersten zehn prozent haben
millionen bekommen und alle anderen viel
durchs netz sie sind schwache soldaten
lane sagte er passe nicht in das system
von oracle die einzige person die dort
entscheidungen treffen
waren verwirrt wer das sagen hat das ist
ziemlich unberechenbar oder zweig wie
eine galaktische kollision bei der zwei
sterne aufeinandertreffen eine ziemlich
heftige explosion
war auf dem vormarsch hinkt er jedoch in
einem wichtigen bereich hinterher wir
kämpfen immer noch um relevanz bei den
anwendungen wir sind weltweit die nummer
zwei bei den anwendungen nummer zwei
hinter sap erp bereich junge diese zwei
wird langsam alt wir sind nummer zwei im
crm hinter siebel aber wir wachsen
schneller als sap und ziele und wir sind
fest entschlossen die nummer eins bei
den anwendungen zu wärmen so wie wir die
nummer eins bei den datenbanken sind
titeln die nummer eins zu werden musste
ellison etwas tun was er lange vermieden
hatte durch übernahmen an neue
technologien mitzukommen
als er zu diesem schluss kam öffnete er
sein portemonnaie und setzt die viel
höher als jeder andere und der
tagesschicht schneller als jeder andere
er wissen wollte neue anwendungs
software mit seiner produktlinie
kombinieren
2003 nahm er die firma peoplesoft bei
einem feindlichen übernahmeversuch ins
visier das justizministerium
verklagte oracle aus kartellrechtlichen
gründen eine übernahme würde das
unternehmen in die lage versetzen die
zinsen rechtswidrig zu erhöhen nach
anderthalbjährigen kampf stellten sich
die gerichte auf oracle seite freilassen
kaufte peoplesoft für 10 3 milliarden
dollar
es ist sehr selten dass jemand von der
regierung verklagt wird man gewinnt ich
meine das beweist nur wieder wie
hartnäckig dieser typ ist die meisten
jungs hätten wohl eher aufgegeben er
wisse nicht mehr was in den nächsten
fünf jahren gab er fast 34 milliarden
dollar für den kauf und 52 unternehmen
habe linie s geschäftsführerin des
technologie forschungsteams bei der
international
er schaute sich um und sah wie sich die
landschaft verändert und wie das
gemetzel das einigen seiner konkurrenten
angetan wurde immer die möglichkeit für
weitere übernahmen
um technologie zu kaufen hinter der
helfer bereit er hat wirklich diesen
ganzen damit tritt
akquisitions lust steigerte sich 2009
mit seinem 7,4 milliarden dollar
schweren trophäen kauf von sun
microsystems dem führenden hardware
unternehmen
2010 richtete er seinen blick auf eine
ganz andere trophäe eine jahrzehntelange
400 millionen dollar obsession wie bmw
oracle racing und entstand im jahr 2000
für ellisons teilnahme am america's cup
bei dem vielleicht ältesten aktiven
preis im internationalen sport
war vollkommen neu gebaut
das boot ist ein
triumph der zu fliegen scheint
die ozeane hatten so etwas noch nicht
gesehen
es besteht absolut kein zweifel dass er
es hasst zu verlieren überhaupt keinen
zweifel
grant dalton es war im america's cup
gegen edison angetreten
wir werden ja auch wieder gegen ihn
antreten dieser mann ist sehr
entschlossen zu gewinnen
am valentinstag 2010 brachte ellison den
america s cup zum ersten mal seit 15
jahren wieder in die usa
[Applaus]
der alte samurai krieger tauchte wieder
auf als sein freund marx als ceo bei
hewlett packard zurücktrat es ging um
vorwürfe der sexuellen belästigung und
unregelmäßigkeiten bei
spesenabrechnungen verließen war
entsetzt und griff den agp vorstand an
stand tags gerade die schlimmste
personalentscheidung getroffen seit die
apple idioten steve jobs entlassen haben
einen monat später verblüffte alles um
die geschäftswelt als er den entlassenen
manager erstellt
die seifenoper von silicon valley ging
weiter als
apotheker zum ceo machte sein ehemaliges
unternehmen smi ist einer der größten
rivalen von oracle
die unternehmen waren in ein 3 jähriges
verfahren wegen urheberrechtsverletzung
verwickelt das im november 2010 zu ende
ging
sap die deutsche softwarefirma oracle
1,3 milliarden dollar zahlen es war der
grösste vergleich aller zeiten für
software piraterie mit diesem schlag
hatte es ein neues blut auf dem
schlachtfeld der informationstechnologie
vergossen und er ist entschlossener denn
je zu gewinnen sind
[Musik]
ein team das man liebt oder hasst und
als konkurrent von larry ellison weiß
ich dass es bei ihm auch so ist
wenn man bedenkt wie erfolgreich
während die meisten visionäre sich um
kopf und kragen reden und sagen oh so
könnte die welt sein sieht larry wie die
welt sein kann und versucht dann auch
sie so zu machen
er begann mit einer 1200 dollar
beteiligung an einem kleinen unternehmen
und baute es durch willenskraft zu einem
der größten softwareunternehmen der welt
auf
[Musik]